Oh
[Music]
so guys we are here celebrating the
holidays and I know you have lots of
tips on how to make people make their
holidays epic tell me a little bit about
I are super excited because you know we
just got married and it's our first
holiday season together which is very
cool I'm from New York she's from South
Carolina so this year we're kind of
doing a like an LA California themed
holiday situation dinner party and we've
actually partnered with American Express
blue cash everyday to come up with
amazing ways like recipes and cool like
crafts and like Rocky's actually wearing
a cool collar we got a little DIY proper
find that all out on the website
American Express comm slash epic every
day tell rock okay yeah we're also
making some food some like signature
dishes that are really simple stuffing
some dates with some cheese and wrapping
you know she's doing her famous separate
dating recipe which is awesome which is
like donuts and challah bread it's a she
great donuts not really we recommend
yeah laughs company it's all about
bringing people together